Isis is now claiming responsibility for
a deadly weekend attack on a nightclub
in Turkey surveillance video shows the
suspect opening fire about an hour into
the New Year he has seen approaching the
Istanbul Club with a rifle
the gunman escaped after the attack
victims came from more than a dozen
countries around the world the gunman
killed 39 people many of them from
outside Turkey nearly 70 others were
injured including one American Turkish
media now reports that police have
detained eight suspects who may be
connected to the shooting Jonathan
Vigliotti is in Istanbul outside of the
scene of the attack Jonathan good
morning good morning club Rana is one of
the most popular nightclubs in this city
it's one of those places where people
line up for hours only to be turned away
at the door today a much different scene
police are lined up a blue tarp has been
set up and behind it investigators
working around the clock to collect
evidence from this massive crime scene
[Music]
cell phone video from inside Club Rana
showed a crowd of 600 ringing in the new
year but just one hour into 2017 the
gunman struck surveillance video shows
him exchanging fire with police outside
on the street bullets ricocheting off a
car a camera then captures him shooting
his way into the club killing a police
officer and a civilian inside he
reportedly shot anyone in his path some
club goers initially thought the shots
were fireworks until people started
dropping to the ground the fashionable
Club attracts local celebrities and
tourists from all over the world
Jacob Rocca business owner from
Greenville Delaware was injured in the
attack a bullet reportedly bounced off
his phone and hit him in his leg Rock
spoke this morning about the attack as
he was getting ready to fly to the US
all I can say is it's a massive tragedy
for me I wake up in the unite United
States side breakfast you guys wake up
and have to think of this it's so so sad
and
I really wish everybody here the best
17,000 police were patrolling the
streets on New Year's Eve a middle wave
of attacks in Turkey in 2016 from Isis
and Kurdish separatists fabrina
increased its own security the Interior
Minister believes the man acted alone
and came prepared leaving in his wake a
shattered nightclub and bloody start to
a new year the attacker remains at large
a manhunt for him continues glad the
Interior Minister believes the shooter
changed outfits before disappearing
amidst the chaos Jonathan Vigliotti
reporting from Istanbul thanks Jonathan